des autocollants des plexiglas du
lavement dans l'école primaire saint
romain on se prépare pour le retour des
élèves qui vraiment qui est adaptée et
c'est fait près de 600 élèves
fréquentent cette école on s'attend à ce
que la moitié d'entre eux reviennent
pourquoi s'arrêter à la station pour se
désinfecter les mains on le pratiquait
avec le deuil des affiches qui sont bons
pour en ajouter une estime et ensuite
yves monfort confiance où il ya une
distance où siècle occupe et les pipes
et de l'enseignant en avant ici plus
rien ne sera comme avant
il n'y aura plus de cloche les élèves
vont rester dans la même salle de classe
toute la journée dès leur arrivée
jusqu'à la fin de la journée
donc c'était la même chose le dîner va
rester en classe les élèves vont rester
ensemble dans ce local si les adultes
vont se promener par contre cuba au
niveau de sa journée les enseignants
vont travailler sur ce qui était
essentielle à revoir pour le passage à
la prochaine année le gymnase la
bibliothèque de l'école vont rester
fermées tout comme le local de musique
et d'arts plastiques qui pourrait
éventuellement devenir des salles de
classe il ya plus d'élèves dans l'école
on veut qu'il y ait le moins possible de
déplacement de contact entre les élèves
mais on veut garder les récréations nous
on essaie de travailler une période où
vont aller à l'extérieur faire
évidemment me joindre le les rafales de
la mine d'or au moins offrir les
récréations comme d'habitude n'est pas
tout le monde enfants ça va être des
rotations
alors que les élèves seront confinés
dans leur classe les concierges de
l'école ne vont se promener partout nos
concierge on devra nettoyer
systématiquement chaque jour
régulièrement passé continuellement dans
l'école pour nettoyer les poignées de
portes les beaux début ou en fin de
certains endroits où les enfants
pourront toucher auront accès même si
les services de garde d'urgence ont
permis aux écoles de développer un
protocole des mesures sanitaires pour
les écoles les défis sont grands
c'est une réorganisation complète vous
savez c'est la coved nous force tous à
repos à recréer un monde qui
complètement différent et ce monde là
c'est pas juste pour de trois semaines
ce qu'on est en train de faire
actuellement c'est un investissement
ici jean philippe robillard radio canada
montréal